taxer au droit notamment par les siennes
merci madame la planète en allant gagner
la lune merci monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le premier
ministre monsieur le premier ministre
terrorisme reste une menace persistante
pour le monde avec la perte de leurs
territoires de guerre en syrie et en
irak
de nombreux combattants djihadistes
tente d'accélérer leur retour sur notre
propre sol et dans les pays voisins
il faut rassurer les français il faut
rassurer nos élus locaux face aux
risques de diffusion de la
radicalisation officier s qui réside sur
notre territoire mais il faut aussi
apporter des réponses plus globale
d'abord en renforçant notre coopération
avec les pays de la méditerranée libye
tunisie égypte pays de retour et de
transit
il faut renforcer notre solidarité
internationale sur le renseignement et
l'information
or que constate-t-on la solidarité
internationale est aujourd'hui remise en
cause à la fois par l'amérique qui
devrait donner l'exemple et qui
fragilise l'otan notre instrument de
sécurité collective et les dernières
décisions du président américain
concernant les ressortissants musulmans
ajoute à ce désordre politique je pense
aussi à l'attitude ambiguë de la turquie
qui fait partie néanmoins de notre
alliance et qui de manière générale
contribue aussi à l'affaiblissement de
l'occident alors certes monsieur le
premier ministre la france est engagée
les partout avec nos forces armées avec
notre diplomatie mais les trop absente
encore des processus politique je pense
en particulier aujourd'hui au moyen
orient alors ma question est la suivante
comment comptez vous renforcer l'action
de la france sa voix dans un contexte
international qui est marqué par le
retour de la force sur le droit
nous attendons vos réponses elles sont
essentielles pour la france elle même et
pour le reste du monde merci merci
madame hamlin la parole est un monsieur
le premier ministre
madame la députée merci pour votre
question qui soulève un certain nombre
de sujets qui sont
au coeur des préoccupations de la
diplomatie française mais pas seulement
qui sont aussi au coeur des discussions
au sein de l'union européenne notamment
entre la france et l'allemagne
d'abord pour répondre précisément la
question que vous m'adressez il ya les
faits et lorsque l'on prend un peu de
recul par rapport à ce qui a été
l'action diplomatique du président de la
république pendant le quinquennat nous
constatons que nous avons été très
présents avec une reconnaissance
d'ailleurs de cette présence comme en
témoigne le dernier sommet afrique
france afrique france de bamako là où le
terrorisme et s'aimer notamment sur la
bande sahélienne est ce que nous avons
fait au mali en raison des valeurs dont
nous nous réclamons ce que nous avons
fait en centrafrique ce que nous faisons
à travers la présence de la force barkan
tout ça montre que dans cette région où
le terrorisme menace ou des crimes sont
commis au nom des valeurs qui sont les
nôtres par les initiatives diplomatiques
que nous prenons nous sommes là nous
sommes également présents au levant et
nous avons pris des initiatives au
levant depuis le début du quinquennat et
nous avons été au moment où la situation
en syrie s'aggraver parmi les premiers a
insisté pour qu'il y ait une solution
politique inclusive considérant
d'ailleurs que sans cette solution
politique inclusive nous n'aurions pas
de possibilité de dures et efficaces de
lutter efficacement contre le terrorisme
et si en juillet 2013 les états unis
avaient pris une autre position que
celle qu'ils ont pris alors que nous
leur demandions de prendre conscience de
ce qu'était la gravité de la situation
l'évolution des choses aurait été très
différente nous avons cessé d'agir dans
cette partie du monde
contrairement à ce que vous laissez
entendre dans votre question nous
l'avons fait au moment où il s'est agi
de prendre la résolution 22 54 du
conseil de sécurité des nations unies
qui conduira un nouveau rendez vous à
genève après que les rencontres d'astana
ont montré leurs limites et se sont
révélées décevantes alors même que dans
cet hémicycle
on nous expliquait qu'il fallait en
reconsidérant tout non violence et toute
notre stratégie nous précipiter dans
l'organisation de ce type de réunion
pour aller plus vite vers des solutions
qui ne
sont pas révélés comme pertinente encore
récemment
nous sommes présents au sein de l'union
européenne plus que nous ne l'avons
jamais été
pour protéger le continent européen
c'est nous qui avons été à l'origine
avec les allemands du renforcement des
moyens de frontex c'est nous qui avons
été à l'origine avec les allemands de la
modification du code frontière schengen
et notamment de la modification de
l'article 16-2 du code frontière
schengen qui permet de faire des
contrôles systématiques aux frontières
extérieures de l'union européenne c'est
nous qui avons été à l'origine de la
mise en place de dispositifs
d'interconnexion des fichiers permettant
de lutter efficacement contre le
terrorisme
c'est nous qui avons été avec les
allemands à l'origine du mandat donné à
madame guérini pour que l'on puisse avec
des pays comme le niger créer les
conditions d'une plus grande maîtrise de
l'immigration économique est régulière
et par conséquent madame la députée sur
tous les sujets que vous avez évoquées
nous avons non seulement été à
l'initiative
mais nous avons aussi obtenu des
résultats dans un monde plus difficile
plus conflictuel plus dangereux qui ne
l'a jamais été
et comme nous avons l'habitude depuis de
très nombreuses années de nous
interpeller
dans cet hémicycle où dans d'autres
enceintes en normandie
je me devais de vous apporter par amitié
par souci de précision
la réponse la plus adéquate à la
question absolument pertinente que vous
avez bien voulu m'adresser